[Música]
bom o tema é catador de sonho as pessoas
só um catador de som e talvez por cada
referência das minhas latinhas que eu
catava latinhas então bacana mas eu falo
o que eu falar um pouquinho sobre hoje
vida real
a diferença entre catar latinha e ter
uma empresa de reciclagem automotivo que
é referência na américa latina com que a
diferença é essa diferença que na
realidade nenhum cresceu tamanho da lata
abandonada
eu sou a mesma pessoa eu sou forte as
pessoas acham que eu sou forte nas no
primeiro carro alemão no primeiro milhão
não se é um equívoco eu sou forte dos
meus valores
as pessoas estão perdendo a referência
de valores
eu vou para os lugares com carlo
objetivo de impactar as pessoas para que
elas voltem pra sua essência e busque lá
a sua fortaleza que está dentro de cada
um de nós os seus valores quais são os
seus valores
quais são os nossos valores as pessoas
estão perdendo essa referência
olha eu nasci numa situação o nosso a
maioria dos brasileiros dá muito tempo
uma condição
eu diria que sem grana mas eu fui buscar
meus jogadores na base na família eu
tinha uma mãe a minha mãe me fortaleceu
nos meus valores a minha mãe dizia pra
mim que ser pobre não era um problema
era uma situação que eu podia mudar só
depende de quanto tempo eu estava
disposto a mim me dedicar a isso
ela dizia que ser negro é um privilégio
porque é que agradecer eu aprendi
agradecer negro com seis anos de idade
então isso também não era um problema
essa mesma mãe dizer que era bonito eu
acreditava na minha mãe
as pessoas estão perdendo a referência
de valores houve quem domina quem ouve
eu aprendi muito cedo a ordem dos
valores um dos valores principais com
aprendi a gratidão
as pessoas põem a mãozinha juntinho na
internet fala de gratidão porque ganhou
um smartphone gratidão é muito mais que
isso eu aprendi a ter gratidão porque eu
morava num barraco que o sol em travas e
dos eu era batido mas eu levantava de
manhã ea mãe dizia que tinha o júri não
foi agradecer a oportunidade de mais um
dia é tudo que eu precisava
é tudo que nós precisamos o dia o tempo
longo do tempo o tempo todo eu aprendi
com a minha mãe é dividir a comida que o
o que sobrava da fira a gente dividia a
ter noção de quanto é importante você
compartilhar e dependendo da sua
condição social que pode ajudar o
próximo e eu aprendi a fazer alguma
coisa pelo próximo muito pequeno também
isso fortalecendo os valores da
espiritualidade mãe dizer que a luz que
entrava no barracão a luz divina e eu
tinha que agradecer acreditar que deus
não sacanear ninguém
nada acontece por acaso tudo é positivo
depende do ponto de vista dos meus
pontos de vista não eram positivos eu
tinha uma mãe que não sabia ler não
sabia escrever pensando a mentora e ali
eu fui me fortalecendo e blindando os
meus valores e divide o resto da comida
pra aprender a dividir o que tinha e era
possível já consegui ajudar o próximo é
aquela consulta naquela situação e assim
foi fortalecendo eu fui crescendo meus
valores
mamãe foi embora quando eu tinha sete
anos e meio por algum motivo levantei de
manhã a agradecer o dia que começou e um
cheiro não achei a minha mãe não achei
do dia seguinte
no terceiro dia pois meu pai na parede
o pai começou a chorar eu entendi que
tinha alguma coisa errada e papai diz
uma mãe morreu morreu com morreu morreu
eu não entendia a referência como é que
se tenha de morrer mas não volta
não tem mais mãe ela não vai me dar um
abraço ela vai dar bom dia não vai dá
tchau como assim
no rio como então até levado ao
cemitério e dizer aqui em baixo não
volto mais a importância que você tem de
resgatar os seus valores
as pessoas se fortalecer novamente
buscar na sua essência a fortaleza que
vai de cada um de nós
eu entendi
uma das principais lições que minha mãe
ensinou na vida quando é que agradecer
quando o dia começava era pra eu ter uma
referência do valor que tem o tempo
quanto vale o seu tempo e eu entendi o
que ela quer dizer o tempo acaba e o
tempo dela acabou que eu entendi que o
tempo dela acabou eu não sofri eu não
chorei mesmo foi parar embaixo de uma
ponte
mas eu fiquei tentando entender as
lições que aprendi com essa fortaleza
com essa coach que foi a minha mãe uma
colt de primeira linha
ela me ensinou os valores e eu me
fortalecido meus valores
eu me brindar lei eu sou blindado até
hoje
ali eu estava pronto personalidade
ninguém precisa que mais de sete anos
para ter personalidade formada e foram
personalidades com sete anos com sete
anos não tem ruim
nós somos bons as pessoas são boas e eu
aprendi a conviver com os diferentes
conviver com as diferenças e nada pra
mim o problema
nós somos o criador tudo o que tem
embaixo de nós é a cria eu aprendi muito
cedo o dinheiro os problemas é seu
responsabilidade sua
deus nos sacanear ninguém deus que tá
aqui eu mesmo paguei de cada um
não tem ninguém mais inteligente maior
ou menor nós somos iguais à semelhança
iguais você precisa acreditar exercer os
seus valores suas crenças sua
credibilidade à sua determinação a fé e
espiritualidade você gigante
nós somos gigantes eu aprendi a lidar
com isso e fui exercer o que minha mãe
me ensinou o tempo dela acabou eu disse
que o meu tempo agora é a lei mais azeda
valor para cada segundo da minha vida
como se fosse o último
todos os dias eu levanto de manhã eu só
preciso do dia
o resto é comigo com o meu trabalho
18 anos trabalhei no cnpj de alguém como
empreendedor jeito de pensar em seguida
eu consegui e trabalhar cada latinha
cara catar latinha um privilégio
as pessoas reclamam lamento perde se
muito tempo era um privilégio
eu agradeci ancp 12 horas o destaque no
carvão agora time o próprio negócio que
estava lá eu achava que comer lá eu
consegui comer passava bem armazenado
anticorpos cara e eu fui crescendo de lá
sempre ajudando alguém depois de
constituir outra coisa outro negócio
aquilo foi crescendo nós sempre ajudando
o próximo e gente eu queria falar um
pouquinho sobre positividade a força da
positividade e os dois livros um catador
de sonho que é o que é referência que
nós temos aqui nesse nosso bate-papo e o
poder da positividade é quando você
consegue brindar sua mente está a
crescer
qualquer máquina qualquer computador que
por maior que seja a geração como alguns
o lucas por exemplo acaba desenvolvendo
laboratório máquina modernidade evolução
inovação não importa quem cria tudo isso
é aqui o que significa que você é maior
que tudo isso você o criador
a única coisa que tem no meu ponto de
vista entre o criador que somos nós que
o que está embaixo de nós é a crise é
menor que nós você é maior que isso não
existe problema maior que você o
dinheiro quando eu ficava sem nas seis
vezes que fiquei sem dinheiro a sua fala
que eu falei que eu quebrei não só
fiquei sem dinheiro senão problema é a
única coisa que você repõe não deixa
sequela o dinheiro os seus valores ea u
e tudo fique abaixo de você você nasceu
primeiro problema é seu os valores o que
vem depois
a única coisa que está acima de você
entre o que eu chamo de energia divina
de universal de deus
a única coisa que está entre você que é
o criador de deus ea sua mulher que ela
manda você mas o resto é perfeito e
assim você toca a vida e eu continuei
tocando continue sendo gerador de
oportunidade é contra lei constitui
empresa a diferença do tamanho da
empresa para mim as latinhas que eu
pegava não faz diferença
eu cantava latinha com paixão e toca à
minha empresa com a mesma paixão por
conseqüência do tamanho da lata é
simples assim pessoas aprender a
conviver com os diferentes gostar das
pessoas como elas são todas as pessoas
são boas elas só são diferentes
olhe pra pessoa ea vale o ponto positivo
80% das pessoas positivo os outros 20%
são resíduos porque nós estamos
inacabados nós somos eternamente
inacabado se você já tiver pronto pegar
porque acabou o seu tempo
onde é que está o tijolinho que te falta
no outro então aprenda a conviver com o
outro apenas com do dia com a diferença
você precisa do outro nós somos
interdependentes
nós estamos no século 21 e as pessoas
não acordaram ainda que nós somos
emocionais
as pessoas fazem tecnologia robotização
armazenamento na nuvem cara as pessoas
resgate os seus valores
a família a base
você tem uma família você não tem
constitua uma onde é que você carrega
suas baterias
onde é que você comece o dia como é que
você faz network network de coração para
coração acorda b com quem tá dormindo do
lado e serve um café dar um abraço
nem que seja pela inteligência de
abraçar o deus que está no outro
culpa do ter percebido mas se você à
semelhança de vídeo de eu sair você está
no outro também aprender a conviver com
as diferenças aceitar as coisas como
elas são e mudar aquilo que você pode
tudo você pode dentro da sua
possibilidade empreender empreender a
vida termina no meu tempo e prender a
vida seria um estofado empreendedorismo
eu falo de empreender a vida acreditar
acreditar no seu país no seu semelhante
na sua segunda mãe que a sua pátria
quando a pessoa sai do país é como você
sair da casa da sua mãe na casa da
madrasta depois de adulto não vai
funcionar se não vai ser feliz dá valor
à sua mãe não está funcionando sua mãe
está com problema ajuda a sua mãe ajuda
à sua pátria que você pode fazer pelo
outro
e não o contrário é o que você pode
fazer em forneceu receber mais um
tijolinho espiritualidade você já tem de
sobra
pensamento positivo você brinca e volta
a crescer como você fala do computador
da nasa que é o mais elevado mais
moderno que tem isso ele foi criado aqui
o que significa que quando você tem um
smartphone ou computador de última
geração ele dá pau você desliga e liga
de novo
gente esse exercício faço todos os dias
eu levanto de manhã eu tenho gratidão
pelo privilégio de ter mais um dia e é
só que eu precisava aí eu venho aqui
dizia essa máquina poderosa e comércio
de novo reinicia deleta aquilo que não
interessa
fortaleça aquilo que está armazenada por
que você reiniciar mas não pede que está
armazenada
mas você pode deletar aquilo que não
interessa se começa de novo você pode
você pode aqui nesse pacto pessoas diz
que é complicado que tudo é difícil que
mimi terceiriza o problema tudo é um
problema
terceiriza culpa vai pro fundo do poço
fica achando que empurrou ninguém por
você no posto não foi você que cavou
assumir responsabilidade
dá um passo à frente e eu venho fazendo
desde pequenininho e se dar certo pra
mim
da favela que nunca teve um
problema maior que eu porque não daria
para o outro porque não daria pouco
nesse mesmo país
empreender é um estado de espírito é
você ser produtiva e gerar oportunidade
para mais alguém você precisa acreditar
acreditar em você
nós somos gigantes esse diamante que nós
ganhamos todos os dias que é o dia e
precisa precisa ser muito grato você
agradeceu o dia que começou com você
reclamou da bala perdida do trânsito e
da chuva e do calor do vizinho gratidão
o dia começou e você é um privilegiado
você existe você está acontecendo não
precisa esperar o carnaval acontece
agora nós temos escritores
a dieta bom essa vontade nós somos
empreendedores natos
o brasileiro é muito bom nós somos
resiliente brasileiro renasce das cinzas
e nem na acisa nós estamos nós só
precisamos acreditar dar a volta e
reiniciar a mentalidade positiva 0
brinda e volta a crescer e crescer como
pessoa bater metas a atingir metas como
o crescimento humano levanta de manhã e
procura fazer uma coisa mais dá um
sorriso a mais um abraço a mais 11 a
troca de carinho criança como ser humano
se você for um grande ser humano
naturalmente você vai ser bom nas outras
coisas que você se propõe a fazer
é simples assim as pessoas entendendo
que tem uma mágica que tem uma uma visão
diferenciada uma situação especial não
simplicidade seja grande e faça as
coisas com simplicidade como se você
tivesse começando tudo de novo não abra
mão dos seus sete anos da sua pureza da
sua bondade da sua facilidade conviver
com o próximo
nós somos a semelhança divina
o deus que está em mim eu deus que está
em todos nós
isso é possível pra mim é possível para
todos nós é isso que eu gostaria o tempo
é curto mas a energia que eu gostaria de
deixar para vocês é crença acredita é
possível o pensamento positivo acredito
em vocês
que deus abençoe a nossa trajetória de
quem com deus
[Aplausos]